6e place royale ce fut de 1832 à 1848
l'adresse de victor hugo à paris
avant ces longues années d'exil la place
royale est devenue maintenant la place
des vosges et la maison du poète vient
d'être rénové après un long sommeil de
vétusté nous nous proposons nous vous
proposons une visite au deuxième étage
qui vient d'être ouvert au public
le reportage de gérard tavera 6 place
des vosges la maison de victor hugo qui
fut un peu celle de la belle au bois
dormant vient d'être rénové et réaménagé
avec des meubles provenant de ces
diverses résidences
on y célébrera en 1985 les fêtes du
centenaire de la mort du poète poètes
des enfants et de l'enfance victor hugo
fut également un grand dessinateur
romantique
il est entre autres l'auteur de ce
clair-obscur tourmenté
victor hugo est encore l'auteur de cette
chinoiseries composé pour le salon de
juliette drouet la plus fidèle de ses
maîtresses qui le suit en exil à
guernesey ses boiseries ces panneaux
pyrogravés sont signés victor hugo hélas
selon le mode andré gide
je
on ne peut qu'aimer cet homme généreux
sa vitalité son habileté mais non point
apprécié le pasticheur décorateur qui a
parfois goûter ce qu'il y avait de plus
mauvais en son siècle
de plus kitsch dire étant aujourd'hui et
c'est l'un des charmes de ce musée que
de montrer cela sans le dire il ya tout
de même de très beaux objets et chargé
de souvenirs et d'émotions
c'est le mérite des conservateurs que
d'avoir regroupé tout cela en se servant
notamment des écrits des fraudeurs
objets témoins de l'exil anglo normand
et de ces adresses parisiennes rue de la
rochefoucauld rue de clichy
sa fille léopoldine
la dernière adresse plutôt 130 avenue
d'eylau où il mourut le 26 mai 1885
avenue à laquelle on donne un sens non
au lendemain des obsèques nationales
victor hugo est mort parmi ces meubles
écritoire pendule elie louis xiii qui
avaient de toute évidence une vocation
de lit de mort